hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe heute endlich mal wieder
nach ganz langer zeit eine ausgabe
nachgemacht original treff sally das
krad selber nicht mehr wie es heißt und
zwar gibt es heute einen bunt rezept vom
murat denn der morath der liebt ganz
gerne dieses kinder paradiso und ich
habe jetzt ganz lange mit dem video
gebraucht und konnte es jetzt erst
finden denn dieses kinderparadies so das
gibt es gar nicht überall
also wir haben das letztes jahr glaube
zum ersten mal gegessen ich zumindest
erkenntnis schon und jetzt haben wir
ganz lange gesucht und wirklich sind
alle supermärkte abgeklappert haben im
internet die gucken mal kunst wirklich
nirgends bestellen
und jetzt gab es über den sommer beim
globus und hat dem rat gleich mal zehn
päckchen mit genommen also zehn so
hörbar 550 stück und da war die halbe
kühlschrank voll
und jetzt gehen sie schon dem ende zu
und es gibt nur noch drei und ich durfte
kein fall von essen und erschafft noch
gehabt noch hätte entweder haben jetzt
das video oder darfst du nicht essen
also geht's heute das video und zwar
weil es nicht kennt kinderparadies so
schmeckt wirklich richtig lecker
sommerliche eigentlich und total locker
das sind so zwei schichten die haben so
eine leichte zitronen note und innen
drin ist so eine leckere mädels gerät
macht mal ausrichter der messe boot noch
im bilde transall ii in rot
ja wer auch so gegangen ja und diesen
halt so hand groß und richtig schön also
die riechen auch schon so zitronig und
so locker und der name paradiese passte
auch wirklich perfekte zu ich weiß dass
gleich rein aber nicht vor der kamera
ich würde sagen wir starten jetzt auch
direkt mit dem teig ich habe mit einem
ganz lockeren teig ausgesucht den hatte
ich auch schon mal für ein dessert
benutzt und damals hat nämlich der murat
gesagt mensch das schmeckt sowie das
kinderparadies also nehme ich auch genau
diesem tag den backofen habe ich schon
vorgeheizt und meinen bart rahmen
bereitgestellt und hier stehen meine
zutaten und zwar brauche ich dafür 200
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und 1
prise salz 50 gramm wasser da habe ich
jetzt ein mineralwasser mit kohlensäure
50 gramm mehl 40 g speisestärke
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver und 40
gramm zerlassene butter und für den
zitronengeschmack natürlich eine bühne
zu treten
meine stärke frankophile ob die stärke
weglassen kann mussten bewirken die
stellt also die bewegt eben dass der
teig favorit da wird und lockerer wird
also ich würde sie nicht weglassen
man kann sie natürlich durch mail
austauschen aber ich finde das macht den
teig einfach viel viel lockerer und
deswegen nehme ich eben gerne die
speisestärke immer mit dazu zuerst gebe
ich jetzt die feier in die schüssel ihr
könnt es natürlich auch einem
handrührgerät machen müsst dann einfach
ein bisschen länger hören
der zucker direkt hinterher
eine prise salz und das von den exakt
jetzt lasse ich das ganz schön cremig
verrührt es dauert jetzt so vier bis
fünf minuten
bei mir ging es jetzt schneller als 45
minuten denn die eier war im zimmer
waren da geht es immer ein bisschen
schneller und ich hab jetzt etwa zwei
minuten rühren müssen jetzt gebe ich
direkt die zitronenschale mit rein
ich finde man könnte es auch als
abwandlung mit orange macht dass sie
winter zum schluss sagen das ist
wirklich nur mit bio zitrone geht nicht
dass die leute versuchen einfach
irgendwelche zitronen zu reiben ja das
stimmt also musik bio zitrone weil die
sind dann ungespritzt und man kann man
eben die schale mit verzeihen
ich hab ein bisschen zu viel ich nehme
jetzt mal nicht die ganze das hebe ich
mir auf kann man auch einfrieren zum
beispiel zitronenschale hat muss ihm auf
vorrat
und jetzt kommt noch das wasser mit rein
lass ich ganz guten einrühren bei
niedriger stufe
es reicht schon man kann der früher
besen weg und jetzt vermisse ich die
trockenen zutaten also mail speisestärke
und eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver und
gibt es dann mit in den teig
ich finde ich eine tolle idee für den
kindergarten kindergartenfest zur
kinderparadies zu machen nicht richtig
toll
kann man schön aus der hand essen so
dass wir jetzt kurz untergehoben genauso
wie die flüssige butter die darf jetzt
auch nicht mehr heiß sein
man sieht es jetzt auch schon das ist
ein richtig schöner lockerer teig
und stehen für mich jetzt in meinen
vorbereiteten back rahmen
ich backe hat ganz gerne im bug rahmen
und nicht auf dem backblech weil ich
beim backen eben auch hier außen diese
90 grad winkel habe als ich habe später
keine abgerundeten ecken sondern ist es
wirklich alles 90 grad und ich kann dann
später den ganzen tag verarbeiten und
außerdem bagdad eick darin viel
schneller und wird er nicht so trocken
weil ich ihn ja dann kürzer backen muss
den jetzt einfach nur schön verstreichen
und so wird er jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für etwa sieben bis neun
minuten gebacken also noch sieben
minuten schauen ich schaue ich ihn mir
schon mal an
es soll auch nicht dunkel werden sondern
einfach nur durch sein und es könnte
dann am besten mit der stäbchen probe
also dem zahnstocher kontrollieren und
der zwischenzeit es ich mal paradiso der
kuchenteig ist jetzt abgekühlt ich habe
den bug rahmen entfernt und habe es
einfach hier auf so ein abkühlen gitter
gesetzt damit einfach schneller abkühlen
das geht dann auch ganz schnell
und jetzt habe ich hier vorne bereits
die zutaten für die füllung das sind
ganz wenige
und zwar ganz bewusst denn dieser teig
schmeckt jetzt so leicht zitronig und
die creme soll es neutral schmecken und
deswegen habe ich mich jetzt für eine
leckere mascarpone sahne creme
entschieden und braucht auch nur vier
zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier 200 g schlagsahne
500 gramm mascarpone 40 gramm
puderzucker dürfen natürlich auch mehr
nehmen
und ich habe hier so abartig habe jetzt
nur 40 gramm puderzucker weil ich eben
später noch das ganze mit süßem schnee
beschreiben möchte
wir streuen möchte und dass man eben
nicht so süß schmeckt weil ich mag es
nicht zu süß genau die hamburger damit
auf den kommentar von mir gewartet es
zuerst die mascarpone in eine
rührschüssel als echten und total
schnelles dass er auch richtig gut
ich bin richtig gut zum thema zum kaffee
war schnell ausgemacht kann auch gut
vorbereiten und kann man sie kühl
stellen
richtig lecker so die mascarpone dann
gebe ich den puderzucker mit rein wie
gesagt könnt ihr auch gerne männer und
es lasse jetzt kurz berühren
jetzt kommt auch direkt die sahne mit
rein das können wir dann zusammen
schreibt schlagen und zum festigen
mascarpone ist zwar schon fest aber ich
möchte auch später dass die paradiso
schön standfest bleiben
deswegen gebe ich da jetzt noch so gut
zwei teelöffel sahne rein lang hat rein
die österreicher werden die freund wieso
will die haben keine sonne park
andere fans stand mittel
ich gebe es noch ein bis zwei teelöffel
mit rein dann wird eben schon fest
jetzt nämlich den abgekühlten talk und
mussten jetzt einmal halbieren
denn dann habe ich einmal die unterseite
dann kommen die creme und dann die
oberseite und da ist bei mir 36 cm breit
und ungefähr 31 cm mehr hat 36 lang und
31 breit
also halte ich den jetzt bei 18
und jetzt habe ich hier so einen eckigen
torten rette den lege ich jetzt drauf
und kann besser drauf
und jetzt streiche ich die creme auf
eine hälfte
ich glaube ich aber bisschen viel creme
gemacht
und damit ist jetzt immer bis zum rand
streichen kann nämlich so eine type
karte zur hilfe dann können dass nämlich
raus streiche ohne dass es eben
überläuft
die hälfte der creme reicht übrigens
auch aus das heißt ich mache gleich noch
mal eine portion und schreibe ich aber
die reduzierte menge auf meinem blog
und jetzt kommt die zweite hälfte drauf
aber ich möchte jetzt dass die mit der
unterseite oben ist als stürzt sich das
einmal kurz sieht kompliziert aus ist es
aber nicht und legte sich getraut
sich das ein riesen paradiso
genial aus ich hab schon gewünscht gar
nichts sagen
die sprache verschlagen weil ich sie so
wie aus dem riesen weißen ich ja
paradiso und bevor ich dieses große
kuchenstück jetzt in kleine stücke
schneiden stelle ich jetzt erstmal für
ungefähr eine halbe stunde mindestens in
den kühlschrank dann wird die creme ein
bisschen fest und dann kann man es
gleich richtig schön schneiden
nein du bist gestorben danach meine
kinder paradiso also mein nachgemacht
ist jetzt schön kalt und jetzt muss ich
noch schneiden
ich habe übrigens ja noch die zweite
ladung gemacht weil ich ja zu viel creme
hatte und da hab ich so gemacht dass ich
zuerst die decke geschnitten habt und
sie dann drauf gelegt habe aber ich
denke sie können muss man es auch ganz
gut schneiden können
aber wenn es nicht so gut geht am besten
vorher einfach mal durchschneiden
schlusslicht essen gestorben nein ich
will erst schneiden und zwei es hat 30
cm lang und ich mache jetzt immer zehn
zentimeter
ich mache das messer zwischendurch immer
wieder sauber damit die oberfläche auch
schön sauber bleibt und jetzt würde ich
sagen jetzt habe ich ja 18 cm in der
breite
ich mache drei vielleicht mittel zu
wenig gelber 4
ja man muss ehrlich ist jetzt wieder
alles auf ich mache habe ich einen
kleinen rest
jetzt kommt mein lieblings tat das
gestrenge rechtsstaates machen
ich mach das mal kurz und da kann man
jetzt ruhig ganz viel puderzucker drauf
machen also süßen schnee ich nehme da
halt den süßen schnee mal der nicht
schmilzt puderzucker schmilzt auf der
oberfläche irgendwann wenn es zu feucht
wird offenbar wie sich auch die süße
schnee drauf genau das ist auch aus
berlin ich auch richtig viel drauf
wichtig grad ja deswegen habe ich einen
der füllung jetzt wenig zucker und hier
steht ziemlich viel drauf wir müssen
nicht übertreiben
wahrscheinlich niesen wenn du das mal
dann der ganze schnee egal also rein
optisch gesehen gleich fast ja also
wirklich super und jetzt ausprobieren
möchte aus der hand essen oder mit einer
gabel ich jetzt doch so handelt weil ich
es ist ja auch gut aus an wo wir das
jetzt mal ich bin gespannt was es noch
kurz mal fürs foto
ich probiere ich finde das schmeckt
super aber aber das kinderparadies
paradiso da ist die creme noch etwas
süßes ja ich hab's halt weniger süß
gemacht mir ist aber auch zu süß also
ich habe nur 40 gramm puderzucker mit
drin aber wenn ihr das gerne süßes
möchtet müsst ihr einfach 60 oder 80
nehmen aber ich persönlich mag es nicht
so süß deswegen habe ich weniger weniger
butter zum angucken und dann sprechen
okay also wenn ihr das auch nach machen
wollt die zutaten gibt's noch mal auf
meinem blog blog de und ja endlich mal
wieder nach gemacht
du kriegst gleich nochmal also super
danke ich es schön anrichten und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann zwei süßen